[Musica]
ciao ragazzi sono di nuovo dentro un
armadio lo so perché questa è la seconda
parte del nascondino con i personaggi
cattivi ma questa volta sono ancora più
paurosi ed inquietanti lo scorso video
vi è piaciuto tantissimo se avete visto
ma mi sembra che ci sia una bambola che
mi sta cercando in questo momento spero
che non si accorga che sono qua dentro
all'armadio prima che mi trovi lasciate
un bel mi piace su questo video
provatela sarà mi piace entro 5 secondi
5 4 1 o tempo scaduto siete riusciti
alla solo mi piace in queste condotte
non mi seguite ancora su in sacra
mandate a seguirmi il nome anita stories
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok e
alla fine del video potrete scrivere nei
commenti qual è il turno il round che vi
ha fatto più paura perché ci saranno
quattro turni quattro round
io ho solamente due vite quindi se perdo
più di due volte ho perso il gioco e non
potrò continuare e non ci sarà una terza
parte
se invece vinco potrà esserci la terza
parte che presso i pop corn
iniziamo subito e vediamo come scappare
da questa bambola
d
[Musica]
si no e rimasto monica stata
dove sta andando si è allontanato avete
visto
vado via
via libera possiamo uscire dall'armadio
eccolo le linee sopra il letto nerino mi
raccomando poi mi da guardie del corpo
anche oggi è ok sono allontanati da lì
si sa chi sono probabile fra perché non
mi abbia visto marino visto non c'è più
ma si muove velocissimamente di aiutarmi
a trovarlo che berlino troppo sonno oggi
per aiutarmi in questa challenge ha
iniziato semi fare qualcosa forse ha
visto qualcosa non merlino impossibile
che sia sotto al letto c'è troppo poco
spazio sotto al letto perciò chi va bene
siccome non lo vedo da nessuna parte
direi che provo a scappare
dell'eccessiva menti fuori dalla porta
se riesco a scappare apro vinto
altrimenti no
berlino andiamo proviamo scappare su non
voler rimanere qui a dormire bene
scattiamo avete visto che ho dimenticato
questo aspetto
berlino fregati sprecati e family
frittatina lasciare un pericolo vieni
[Musica]
ragazzi abbiamo vinto il primo turno non
so come siamo riusciti a scappare it
acciacchi forse perché merlino li ha
peccato alla fase cioè chi è rimasto
tipo pietrificata è comunque ora siamo
al secondo round secondo turno non so
ancora chi sia il cattivo del secondo
turno un po paura che spunterà fuori
all'improvviso come tutti gli altri
quindi teniamo gli occhi bene aperti
iniziamo a cercare un nascondiglio
perché il cattivo potrebbe comparire da
un momento all'altro
avete capito chi è il cattivo e ben di
forse devo evitare quella direzione e
andare qua proviamo andare qua tu che
dici merlino da che parte andiamo a
destra oa sinistra e nel cartone
vi ricordate nella challenge trova gli
ingredienti ben nascosti da ben di lui
usa il cartone di se stesso per
distrarmi quindi lui potrebbe essere qua
ho qua
dove marino cerca cerca berlino
finiscono borsa ok allora meglio
cambiare direzione
beh io me ne sono poi studiati non
potrai mai prendermi babies cosa chi è
chi è ben sei stato tu a bussare
no non è possibile che sei stato tutto
non è le mani ai le zampe dignitosa che
passa coperto se mi disse volta alla
parte opposta
andiamo di quattro da che parte ndiamo
sopra le stelle
cosa vorrà dire dei monti del liuto non
deve sopra la scheda sopra le scale
potrebbe esserci pendi ma anche a destra
potrebbe esser si vende non mi fido
secondo me un tranello quello del
cartonato quindi proposta lire sopra le
scale
ok ragazzi saliamo le scale speriamo che
sia la scelta giusta
citiamo la porta qua casomai arrivi 20
capito
piano non mi sembra che ci sia nessuno
ecco se questo rumore
merlino grazie per avermi svegliato ma
abbiamo perso il secondo round
quindi ho già perso una vita mi rimane
solamente una vita
questo è il terzo e penultimo round che
sarà il cattivo
non lo so ma è meglio se cerchiamo
subito un nascondiglio andare verso ben
di non è stata una buona idea
quindi questa volta voglio nascondermi e
rimanere immobile così chiunque sia il
cattivo non mi troverò spero siamo
nuovamente in studio e se vi ricordate
nell'altro episodio quando mi sono
nascosta sopra al letto a castello nel
letto di sopra sono riuscita a vedere
granny che entrava e tirarle un pupazzo
ed è andata abbastanza bene devo dire
tranne che poi era nascosta nell'armadio
ma provo anche questa volta stare sopra
il letto così il cattivo probabilmente
non mi vedo che c'è qualcosa di bianco
in mente nessuno molto bianco forse un
fantasma
dobbiamo prendere qualcosa per
difendersi dal fantasma prima di salire
sopra al letto
devo trovare un lenzuolo o qualcosa del
genere che sono in bagno ho preso un
asciugamano perché i lenzuoli sono in
camera da letto e ho paura che fantasma
zero in capre balletto ora scappiamo
subito bene i ragazzi sono nel mio
nascondiglio preferito sopra letto con
tutti i pupazzi e ho qua l'asciugamano
in caso di difesa dal fantasma credo che
sia un fantasma
[Musica]
provo a tirargli l'asciugamano in testa
ora lo abbraccio spero che funziona
[Musica]
speriamo
ho solo una possibilità se non riesco a
beccarlo si accorgerà di me sì già fatta
ma perché è rimasto immobile che succede
che succede non si muove più
è scoperto guardati rimasto solo lo sci
lavoro per terra abbiamo vinto questo
torno questo round per fortuna perché mi
rimaneva solo una vita e ora passiamo al
quarto turno e vediamo chi è il cattivo
finale
[Musica]
per l'ultimo turno ho deciso di scendere
al piano di sotto
andiamo assieme e scopriamo chi è
l'ultimo cattivo eccoci qua al piano di
sotto
ancora non è comparsa nessuno dato il
nostro confermi dietrologia
nell animo
[Musica]
che mi sono nascosta quasi zero la porta
berlino ha avuto un'idea sul tavolo ci
sono dei fiori
io proverò a lanciare i fiori in
un'altra direzione
così lui forse seguirà il rumore perché
vi ricordate che bisogna a distrarlo e
lanciare le cose lui senti rumori e va
da un'altra parte
e quando lui sarà distratto proverò a
scappare al piano di sopra
speriamo di riuscirci
st
quello che merlino non mangia i fiori
adesso marino di berlino ha continuato
si disse ok
capiamo ce l'abbiamo fatta ci è mancato
un pelo come lo neighbor farò se
l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo perso solo una
vita ma se volete vedere una terza parte
con altri cattivi
lasciate un bel mi piace su questo video
fatemi sapere nei commenti
con il round che vi ha fatto più paura e
ora vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao